-My next guest is currently
in his ninth season
of "Chicago Fire," which airs
Wednesday nights at 9:00 p.m.
on NBC and is streaming
on Peacock right now.
Here is Taylor Kinney!
Taylor!
-Hey!
-It is so nice to see you.
And thank you so much
for coming on the show.
I've actually met you before
but very briefly.
-This was, I forget the year --
2016, maybe something like that.
But every year -- I think
I've done it four times --
we do a Polar Plunge,
which is a charity event
for the Special Olympics
in Chicago.
They wait for, you know,
in and around the coldest day
of the year and they push
some ice and debris
up from Lake Michigan.
You get your swim trunks on,
and you jump in.
And it's gotten bigger,
the crowds.
But I remember you were there.
Vince Vaughn was there, and I
remember you had a suit on.
And you went, like,
just all full suit.
And I go,
"How's he gonna get out?
That's gotta be, like,
triple as cold."
-Look, there it is right there.
-There you go.
-I remember seeing you. My hair
was frozen. It was spiky.
-Oh, yeah, everything
just goes --
-Ice.
-Yeah.
And I'm sure your suit is
still probably stiff as a board.
-It's thawing out, yeah.
It's halfway from Chicago
to New York. Yeah.
But I love that you did that
four times.
Good for you.
That's unbelievable.
It's not a surprise to me
that you do these things
'cause you're in great shape.
But also you like
a good challenge.
I know you and your brothers
have big grilling competitions
with each other.
-Yeah.
-How did that start?
-I kind of grew up on
fish sticks and meat loaf
and leftover fish sticks
and leftover chicken.
And so it was always --
I just expected things
to taste like that.
And I was working a lot.
I started kind of coming home
and grilling on my own,
like, towards the end of high
school, beginning of college.
I would go, if I was doing
carpentry work or roofing,
I started grilling, and I
started with these marinades.
And then, it was like,
"Hey, Mom, like,
you actually can make chicken
that doesn't crack and dry.
Like, this is delicious.
It's kind of good."
And so it was a joke with that,
and then we got more into it,
started writing down recipes.
My brothers got in on it.
And then it became
a competition of sorts
and it just kind of took off.
-Well, you took it
to the next level.
You actually bought
a restaurant.
-So, I own -- part-own
a restaurant and theater
in Lancaster, Pennsylvania.
It's called Zoetropolis
and Lancaster Distilleries.
The theater --
It's a small theater.
We do independent film
documentaries, live music.
It's not a big venue, maybe
90-person capacity pre-COVID.
It's helping a lot of people
who are in between jobs
and in and out of work.
-Please support
your local stuff. Yeah.
-If you ever get a chance, like,
come and do a little stage --
a little set on the stage
there at Zoetropolis.
-If you have an open mike,
I can't help myself.
I have to go up
and grab onto it.
Zoetropolis?
-Zoetropolis is the theater.
Lancaster Distilleries
is the restaurant.
-Alright. Watch me.
I'm going to come.
I'm going to come for you.
-[ Laughs ] I love it.
-I want to say
congrats on "Chicago Fire."
It's a giant hit.
I mean, this is season 9 now?
-Yes.
-I mean, what is it like
when you first get that job
and you go,
"Oh, this could be fun.
Let's see if we can do this."
Cut to -- what is it? --
10 years later now.
You're still --
You're crushing it.
It's still a major hit on NBC.
-It was one of those things --
I had done pilots before.
Either they go --
they don't get picked up.
It's kind of --
You know, it's a crap shoot.
You don't know.
But, you know, with Dick Wolf
being a part of this
and "Law and Order," I said,
"Well, this could have
some legs."
I think it was one of
our producers saying
or a showrunner said,
"Hey, you might want to
look into getting a place.
Not buying but just,
hey, you're going to --
Get out of the hotel."
And it's been nine years now.
-Wow!
-It's the closest thing as
a 9:00 to 5:00 that I think
that I'll experience
in this line of work.
-I'm a fan of the show,
and I have to ask,
because I used to live
by a fire station
when I was first
on "Saturday Night Live."
And they are
a very honest bunch.
Do you hear from
real firefighters who watch
and go like, "We would never do
that. What are you doing?"
-For the most part,
it was positive responses.
But I think in the first couple
episodes, they were like,
"Well, you guys,
you got this hose.
You slid down this hose.
How the hell are you
gonna get back up?
We don't do that.
What is that?"
-"It's a TV show!
It's a television show!
We're not really firefighters."
-That's what I said.
I was like, "There's
a little creative license."
They're like,
"What are you talking about?
No, no."
-Taylor, thanks so much
for coming on the show, man.
I'm a big fan.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Taylor Kinney
in "Chicago Fire."
Take a look at this.
-You alright?
-Just waiting for some aspirin
to kick in.
What's up?
-Do you know anything
about the delivery
Stella ordered
for the apartment?
-Delivery of what?
-That's the thing.
She wouldn't say.
I don't deal well with change.
She knows that.
-Well, it's her home, too.
She probably wants to put
her stamp on the place.
-Mm. Probably.
-Hey, uh, you and Kidd,
if it's time for me to move on
and you guys need the loft to
yourselves, just say the word.
I promise. I'm all good.
-Didn't I just say I don't
deal well with change?
-Taylor Kinney.
"Chicago Fire" airs Wednesdays
at 9:00 p.m. on NBC.
And every season is streaming
right now on Peacock.